Trump he essentially his innovation was
to recognize from the start that the
campaign is just really a bad reality
show and he made it a good reality show
no that's not saying that qualitatively
he was a good person I'm just saying
that he knew how to make good television
you know how you know knew how to
attract eyeballs it's entertainment if
you think about the the financial
incentives of everybody on the bus or on
the campaign plane you have the
candidates who are funded by a you know
a very small group of ultra powerful
commercial donors and then you have the
press and they're there they're
basically funded by advertising dollars
and so there's just somewhere along the
line there's a synergy between the
person who was the most entertaining on
the one hand and who was able to satisfy
the donor class on the other hand if you
find that sweet spot in the middle of
those two phenomena that's usually where
you were going to get your candidate is
someone who was a little bit
entertaining and also a little bit
morally flexible as a result of that at
the outset of the campaign especially he
was able to attract mountains and you
know billions of dollars probably free
coverage at a period of the race when
other candidates have to buy their own
publicity and he made it into a kind of
a genuine revolt where his voters
perceived themselves as kind of the
aggrieved victims of a conspiracy
beliefs that were represented by all the
you know the donors the press the two
parties and he managed to get asked a
lot of the kind of the bull works that
we usually had thrown up in the past to
keep him people that got out like for
instance normally when a candidate flips
up and makes a mistake I'll our Dean
when he made a scream or Gary Hart when
it got busted with you know with the
monkey business photo you know we
typically used to descend upon a
candidate a reporter I know used to call
it the seal of death where you know we
would going to swirl around a candidate
with negative attention and that would
really be it you know a few hundred
times it would show
damn and clip and the person would just
exit the scene there'd be humiliating
public apology and then a few a drop in
the polls in a few weeks later you
wouldn't hear from that candidate again
that didn't happen this time this is a
trump managed to survive countless
scandals like that and every time
everybody expected him to go down in the
polls he went up in the polls and I
think a lot of people in our profession
were we're kind of flummoxed by that
they would sort of defying the usual
laws of gravity and we just didn't know
what to do about it
[Music]